for someone on your cameras be sure to
check the door lock you might yeah thank
you so much I love you mwah see you in
Hell when I get there
it's gonna be soon okay you sons of
I'm gonna weed Oh God yours is just as
creepy as Iram I mean just as beautiful
as I remember you're the best
you're a shining butterfly in my
nightmare of dreams okay so maybe my
problem I'd actually don't know if my
problem was that I was staring at
Pirates Cove too much or if I was just
bound to die from the get-go oh good
hi are you oh god no where'd you go
huh what you go so yes using the camera
does take more power so I got a whenever
I glance I can't stare in the camera I
just have to take quick glances wherever
I go just to make sure that the
situation hasn't changed yet that's what
I gotta do so I just gotta take quick
glances every once in a while I'll be
fine so on some and change I'm good okay
some change
hurry here here here one was it other
what's the other guy
thought I'd check hi
what's coming down the hall as long as
nothing changes
oh you're out already boy wait a minute
we need to talk about this you need to
go got it
okay you go no no I know not enough no
no I don't want to look at you I don't
even want to look at Oh God are gonna
yeah okay just glancing taking a quick
look I'm sorry I'm sorry for my spouse
hi
how long does he stay there
hello exile air okay yeah yeah yeah you
best run off
hey welcome here bunny over there duckie
over there
Marco man still not happy but that's
okay
we're having a fun time in the nighttime
dancing through our lively head and then
we're going to die very painfully are
coming we go there he is
where's mr. ducky ducky still stuck to
that one spot
he's moving his woman
that's our ears out
Oh Oh try to conserve power very
concerned oh I am so right now
where are they where are they your ducky
right there was bunny step funny man but
no you're not no oh oh you're right
outside my door
ducky is like stuck there like glue
nananana nanana why is it so sorry I am
where's ducky
okay still Stuckey Stuckey dodo still
there better run
yeah that's right back off loser Oh
duckies are coming duckie so coming oh
god oh god oh god oh boy I am oh honey
Lou oh well there's no goddamn active
what's gonna be like the other nights
oh hi donkey
I'm coming where's bunny
where's buddy
okay they're both coming down the
hallways but I'm gonna be okay
I got enough power just very careful
about the oh god oh god oh god
I like this I like it at all
I don't like it at all no no no no no no
no no no no no okay no no but why are
you standing there you could be standing
anywhere but there
I'm a big baby I'm a big boy no you
don't know you no no no no no that's not
the door are you writing out a dark I go
to you ASAP someone in but not no you do
not
that's all goes you know no dick with me
told you there
still there
Oh God dollar commensal there
okay that's cool cool it off or are you
guys there's ducky that's bunny this
fire cold man
yes oh yes oh god I swear my haters
cares so much
Oh